[Musique]
dans la dernière semaine de là
présidentielle nous aurons un grave
incident alors ça a été ou est un
meurtre ça a été mais ras en 2012
ça a été l'attentât la dernière semaine
sur les champs elysées vous rappeler
tout ça c'était la dernière semaine
immédiatement les réactions pleuvent sur
les réseaux sociaux le chef de la france
insoumise est accusé de complotisme
c'est à vomir
je suis sidéré par ce qu'a pu dire jean
luc mélenchon en essayant d
instrumentaliser un drame des meurtres
hier on a eu des propos complotistes
terribles qui ont suscité plus qu'une
émotion je vous aurais vraiment une
indignation et y compris jusque dans les
rangs des familles des victimes je crois
que les propos de madame latifa idia tel
était très doux à cet égard les propos
de jean-luc mélenchon sont inadmissibles
et ne devrait même pas être tenus le
respect c'est un minimum pour l'honneur
de mon fils d autres victimes et des
familles endeuillées
à l'évidence certains ont sincèrement
était blessée par les propos qui ont été
tenus et d'autres ont volontairement mal
compris et déformé les propos de
jean-luc mélenchon jean luc mélenchon il
a toujours c'est un peu d'outrance mais
là qu'il parte dans le complotisme qu'il
insulte la mémoire des personnes qui ont
été assassinées
je trouve que c'est grave et extrêmement
décevant de sa part
je pense que c'est très grave
d'alimenter ce cette dimension
complotistes en france alors que le
risque terroriste
il existe qui peut imaginer un seul
instant que des attentats et étaient
organisés à la veille des élections
présidentielles que ce soit ils parlent
de 2017 me parle de 2012 également pour
pourquoi pour faire voter dans un sens
ou dans un autre
je pense que là monsieur mélenchon il
appuie les pièces sur terre on islamo
gauchistes ont les complotistes nommé
faut arrêter vraiment inventé de toutes
pièces ce genre de polémique
c'est insupportable le débat politique
qu'ils méritent autre chose que cela
un peu de respect je pense que jean luc
mélenchon tout compris de la manière
dont vous fonctionnez pour vous
personnellement mais les médias tant
qu'il a sorti une phrase je vois que ce
matin là manifestement réussi puisque on
ne parle que de ça en tout cas de
l'utiliser politiquement de cette
manière je trouve ça assez à blaye que
je pense qu'il serait bon qu'il qu'il
retire ses propos en tout cas
qu'ils les corrige ce qu'ils disent et
les assassins les assassins qui font ça
savent à quel moment ils le font et
comment ça peut être bien sûr que oui
madame sais pas ce qu'il dit qu'est-ce
que lors la dernière semaine de la
campagne c'est le ton grave et la mine
des mauvais jours que jean luc mélenchon
lance sa contre-offensive dans une vidéo
publiée aujourd'hui à 15 heures
il se dit victime d'un appel au meurtre
en cause un clip diffusé hier sur
internet du youtube heures d'extrême
droite papa si tôt ils ont été manipulés
mais déclare que vous voulez dire non
que jean luc mélenchon et complotistes
c'est ridicule question c'est ridicule
ce n'est pas ce qu'il dit ne peut être
question que nous acceptions ni
maintenant ni jamais qu'on en vienne à
la menace physique au terrorisme
intellectuel qui précède toujours le
terrorisme physique ce qui manque à
notre classe politique c'est le
diagnostic de marine le pen à emmanuel
macron ils ne comprennent pas ce qu'il
se passe
le prince harry et meghan markle on
annonçait la naissance de leur deuxième
enfant
il s'agit d'une fille elle est née
vendredi matin en californie et son nom
et lili bête et diana
peut-être qu'il faut passer à l'action
parce que la la la la prévision la
prédiction même la prophétie ne suffit
pas un hommage d'abord à la mère du
prince harry mais surtout à la reine
elizabeth surnommé lily bêtes par son
époux